just a couple of minutes after the
Colorado Supreme Court ruled yesterday
that the presidential FrontRunner was
ineligible to appear on the ballot a
giddy MSNBC anchor immediately started
paging through the Court's opinion on
air and after a little while she
stumbled on what I think is the single
most important part of the decision this
is the portion of the ruling that uh
isn't about the technical definition of
an Insurrection or about parsing whether
a president is considered an officer of
the United States within the meaning of
the 14th Amendment now to be clear as as
many legal experts have said
uh those are important aspects of the
opinion and I'll get to them in a second
but for now I'm referring instead to the
section of the Court's opinion that
addresses whether under the First
Amendment Donald Trump can be considered
a violent insurrectionist merely because
of his political speech uh this part of
the ruling begins on page 116 and it's
especially important because it applies
to everyone it doesn't just affect
presidential Front Runners and
candidates for office it has the
potential to affect every American who
engages in political speech of any any
kind at all long after Donald Trump uh
is gone so here's how the MSNBC anchor
covered this part of the opinion live on
air last night watch in addition Glenn
The District Court did not a in
concluding that the events at the US
capital on January 6 2021 constituted a
quote Insurrection The District Court
did not air in concluding that President
Trump engaged in and that's in quotes
that Insurrection through his personal
actions and then president Trump's
speech inciting the crowd that breached
the US capital on January 6 was not
protected by the First Amendment Glenn
we've been talking for days if not weeks
about this idea of Donald Trump trying
to hide behind the First Amendment to be
able to give an excuse for what is
otherwise going to be clear criminal
conduct your thoughts about what this
Supreme Court um kind of ruling has now
said as
well okay we don't need his thoughts the
most important part there is where she
says we've been talking for days if not
weeks about Donald Trump trying to hide
behind the First Amendment to give an
excuse excuse for what is otherwise
going to be clear criminal conduct so
she's relieved to report now that Donald
Trump can't hide behind the First
Amendment and that's how someone calling
herself a journalist at a major media
Outlets is describing the single most
important amendment that we have in the
Constitution and they put it right there
at number one First Amendment now
apparently the first amendment is just
something that msnbc's political
opponents like to hide behind in msc's
view it's it's a mere technicality
designed to she criminal conduct that's
how the corporate media views the
Constitution at this point that's how
they viewed it for a very long time they
see it as a sort of temporary obstacle
to imprisoning Joe Biden's primary
political opponent so let's get specific
about what the Colorado Supreme Court
said about the First Amendment and why
they're claiming that it doesn't protect
Donald Trump from this charge of
insurrection under the Insurrection
Clause of the 14th Amendment uh these
specifics matter because they highlight
how easily this decision can be used to
crush any political speech that the left
doesn't approve of that's the whole
point so on page23 the Colorado Supreme
Court begins its explanation of why
Donald Trump was supposedly inciting a
violent Insurrection on January 6
instead of engaging in lawful political
speech but they don't start with
anything that Trump actually said on
January 6 instead they go back several
years so quoting from the decision which
cites the district court uh quote at a
February 2016th rally president Trump
told his supporters that in the old days
a protester would be carried out on a
stretcher and that he would like to
punch him in the face in March 2016
president Trump responded to questions
about his supporters of Violence by
saying it was very very appropriate and
we need a little bit more of it and
during the 2020 election cycle president
Trump threatened to deploy the military
to Minneapolis to shoot looters amid
protests over the police killing of
George
Floyd now again these are a series of
comments taken out of context by the way
but let's put that to the side for a
moment that Donald Trump made long
before January 6 2021 so why are we
talking about that I mean in some cases
these comments occurred more than four
years
earlier and they obviously have nothing
whatsoever to do with January 6th or
voter fraud or anything like it but the
Supreme Court says that somehow these
comments are evidence that Donald Trump
committed Insurrection on January
6th they proof that he intended to
incite violence on that day but how
could that be you know it's like if guy
is charged with murder and the
prosecutor brings up during the trial
that the same guy got a parking ticket 5
years ago I mean what does that have to
do with
anything now to square the circle the
Supreme Court relies and I'm not making
this up by the way uh on the testimony
of a sociology professor at Chapman
University named Peter Simi so this
random professor of Sociology apparently
convinced both the district court and
the Supreme Court that Donald Trump
knows how to quote deploy a shared coded
language with his violent
supporters and supposedly Donald Trump's
statements from 2016 to 2020 are
evidence that he deploys this code all
the time this secret code even though he
didn't in fact use the military to crush
the BLM riots or have any protesters
beat up at his rallies none of that
happened you think if he was using
violent coded language for years that
some violence would have resulted from
it but apparently not still this
professor has discovered like the verbal
invisible ink you know the words that
are written in the margins that nobody
can see but him with his magical Dakota
ring that's what we're supposed to
believe the sociology Professor
testifies that based on Donald Trump's
statements from 2016 to 2020 we can
conclude that all of his comments on
January 6th about fighting to preserve
the country and so on were really coded
language designed to incite a mob to
commit acts of violence at the capital
that's the
argument this is not simply a reach
I mean this decision if upheld is the
end of freedom of speech in this country
not just for Donald Trump but for
everyone to to arrive at its decision
the Colorado Supreme Court used past
comments that they just didn't like not
there was nothing they weren't illegal
just didn't like them in order to twist
the meaning of what Donald Trump
actually said on January 6 now if you
remember in his remarks on January 6
Donald Trump did not tell his supporters
to commit any acts of violence or do
anything illegal or any uh AC of
Insurrection whatsoever instead he
specifically told his reporters to head
to the capital and protest quote
peacefully let's watch that again I know
that everyone here will soon be marching
over to the Capitol Building to
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard today we will see whether
Republicans stand strong for
integrity of our elections so we're
supposed to disregard the fact that
Trump told his supporters to be peaceful
on January 6 this according to the
Colorado supreme court because he said
some stuff that they didn't like back in
2016 and therefore Trump's address to
the crowd uh on January 6th was was a
really a coded message calling for
violence but we need to bring in the
sociology Professor to to crack the code
in its opinion the colado Supreme Court
barely even acknowledges that Trump
explicitly told his supporters to be
peaceful on January 6th on page 127 they
dismissed this as an isolated reference
that doesn't neutralize anything
unpleasant that Donald Trump has ever
said therefore even though he explicitly
called for peace we could just ignore
that and conclude that he was really
calling for the violent overthrow of the
federal
government so you see how this works
there they're taking Donald Trump's
explicit call for peace and just
discarding it out of hand at the same
time they're accusing Donald Trump of
making implicit calls for violence going
back several years and concluding that
it amounts to an Insurrection within the
meaning of the 14th Amendment and to
reach the conclusion as the dissenting
opinion notes the Colorado Supreme Court
never afforded Donald Trump any due
process concerning the determination of
whether an Insurrection had even
occurred at
all the Colorado Supreme Court didn't
bother with the inconvenient fact that
there's a federal Insurrection law on
the books and Donald Trump has never
been charged with violating it well if
you're single you've probably seen or
heard about all the insane dating apps
out there but what if I told you there
was a dating app that actually cared
about your morals and biblical values
higher bond is a new Christian dating
app built to be safer less stressful and
more Christ centered higher bond is
completely different than anything else
out there there's no addictive swiping
focuses truly on quality over quantity
and is designed to form lasting
marriages higher bond is veteran owned
by a husband and wife looking to change
the way Christian singles meet online
it's no secret that left-wing media and
big tech companies are against companies
like higher bond in fact one of the
major big tech companies is preventing
higher bond from running ads on their
platform if you're single you need to
check out higher bond.com sign up before
December 31st and get three months of
higher Bond premium absolutely free
that's higher bond.com today are you
struggling with back taxes or unfiled
Returns the IRS is escalating
collections by adding 20,000 new agents
while in these challenging times your
best defense is to use tax Network USA
with over 14 years of experience tax
Network USA has saved their clients
over1 billion dollar in back taxes they
specialize in negotiating with the IRS
and they aim to reduce your debt
significantly Tax netware USA doesn't
just negotiate they protect your assets
from IRS seizures and manage your yearly
returns for ongoing compliance they're
licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US seize control of your financial
future now and don't let tax issues
overpower you contact tax tax Network
USA for immediate relief and expert
guidance call 855
22514 or visit TN
usa.com Walsh turn to tax Network USA
and find your path to financial peace of
mind that's TN usa.com
Walsh now in case your memory is a
little bit foggy let me remind you that
Donald Trump did not lead an army to
overthrow the government or even to
suede from it he didn't he didn't form
his own country or announce his intent
to do so instead Trump was trying to
maintain the status quo by telling Mike
Pence to reject electors that he
believed were fraudulent Trump was the
chief executive of the government on
January 6 and he wanted to remain the
head of the government as legal analyst
Nick Rak pointed out last atlanto his
YouTube channel a government cannot lead
an Insurrection against itself or or if
it can there's zero evidence that the
14th amendment was ever intended to
apply to an unprecedented situation like
that so to recap the Colorado Supreme
Court didn't have a conviction against
Donald Trump for uh Insurrection nor did
they have any reason to think that 14th
Amendment applied to what Donald Trump
did um but they decided that didn't
matter they just unilaterally decided on
their own um you know that they know
what the word insurrection means and
they uh and they went with it by the
same logic Joe Biden and Cala Harris
could be disqualified for you know
inciting violence all across the country
in 2020 including riots riots at a
federal courthouse in Portland and at
the White House including riots that
burned down a a a a police station in
Minneapolis so we can now have an
endless tit fortat of political
disqualifications in various courts
instead of actual elections that's
according to the logic from the Colorado
Supreme Court that is the
precedent that they would seemingly be
be intentionally trying to
set now I could go on about all the
other problems with this ruling other
commentators and several federal courts
have already pointed out that the
president under the 14th Amendment isn't
even capable of being barred from the
ballot as an insurrectionist the
Constitution spells out exactly who can
be barred from from uh for committing
Insurrection and the president is not
named senators are named representatives
are named electors for President and
Vice President are named but not
presidents themselves
now I can also go into the various
political ramifications of this decision
yes this particular ruling is almost
certainly going to be overturned by the
US Supreme Court in fact the ruling has
already stayed pending the Supreme
Court's review and yes it's a clearly
partisan
document every single member of the K
Supreme Court was appointed by a
Democrat Governor and even then the
decision in this case was still four
to3 there's also the whole absurdity of
every single state supreme court Supreme
Court separately making a decision that
clearly has implications for a National
presidential election so it's not
remotely clear how Colorado has
jurisdiction to even do that according
to the text of the 14th Amendment John
Bolton just to show you how weak the
case is John Bolton who is a not exactly
a trump Ally outline this problem on CNN
last night
watch I think it's completely misplaced
I think this this Colorado Supreme Court
decision is badly wrong for multiple
reasons number one the the 14th
Amendment provides that Congress can
pass legislation to carry uh its
Provisions into effect which Congress
has done on many aspects it has not put
anything with respect the section three
on the books uh since just after the
Civil War uh second the the idea that uh
50 different state courts can can decide
a question involving the highest
elective office in the executive branch
interpreting the Federal Constitution as
to what constitutes an Insurrection
against the federal government uh is is
incoherent and I think undoubtedly the
Supreme Court's going to have to clear
that up in terms of what the framers of
the 14th Amendment meant uh I I think I
think it's quite clear that The Radical
Republicans in Congress who wanted to
suppress The secessionist Advocates and
governments of the southern states that
succeeded would not provide on this
critical question of uh the offices that
that are going to be denied to people
who broke their oath to the United
States that you're going to put
decision-making Authority on that in the
hands of the States including the former
secessionist states that if that was
their intention they were they were
delusional when they did it so I'd be
willing to bet a small amount of money
here that the Supreme Court uh if it
gets to the merits of this if it has to
uh will reverse there's there's no other
logical way you can uh apply this and
and it would seow chaos in elections as
far as the eye could see so you can make
a lot of other uh points too about the
Limited this decision will have
regardless of what the US Supreme Court
does you can note that Colorado is a
state that obviously isn't going to
determine the outcome of the next
election if anything this decision will
probably help Donald Trump in the polls
and already Colorado Republicans have
suggested that they'll simply hold their
own caucus and submit the results to
Congress which if it's Republican
controlled can simply reject any Biden
electors from the state on the grounds
that no fair election took place in
other words it's possible that this
decision will actually cost Joe Biden
electoral votes from Colorado a state
that he's virtually guaranteed to win
otherwise but even if this Colorado
ruling is overturned tomorrow and even
if no other state supreme court issues a
ruling like it the fact remains that
this decision out of Colorado highlights
a much deeper issue that will not go
away journalists and leading political
figures in this country are now openly
saying that their political opponents
should not have a say in elections
they've been building to this point for
a while of course they've been
imprisoning meme makers and and raiding
the homes of pro-lifers and
investigating parents for criticizing
trans propaganda in schools they've been
doing all of that but in the wake of
this Colorado decision it's now totally
explicit so here was Congressman Jamie
Rasin yesterday for
example this is just a question of law
it's like if a 14-year-old tried to run
for president would that person be kept
off of uh the ballot because the
Constitution says you have to be 35
years old to run for president and this
disqualification Clause says you cannot
be on the ballot for president or you
cannot serve as president if you have
participated in Insurrection or
Rebellion against the United States and
so I would think that regardless of what
your politics are what your party is
everybody should agree that this is a
question of law that's got to be settled
by the
court everybody should agree that this
should be settled by the courts well
actually no four judges selected by
Democrat Governors should not in fact
settle the issue of whether American
citizens can vote for the clear front
runner in a presidential election it's
hard to believe that anyone with any
amount of Shame would even suggest
something like that but there's a
sitting US senator or Congressman rather
explaining that to uphold the law you
need to uh you need to agree with him on
this
point once again you're being told that
in the name of the law you should accept
a decision that shocks the conscience of
any reasonable person you're told that
the same Constitution that explicitly
guarantees your right to freedom of
speech in reality is actually
restricting
it now from a historical perspective
this is nothing new you might remember
that the USSR had a constitution
complete with guarantees for freedom of
speech and political
expression didn't work out too well for
them that's because the Soviets
discovered that words in a constitution
aren't actually self-
enforcing right there's nothing magical
here they're just they're words they can
be
discarded you need a population and
elected officials who actually respect
the do
doent if they don't then it's trivially
easy for them to twist the words of the
Constitution around to the point that
they become meaningless or that they
actually do the opposite of what they're
intended to
do that was Justice scalia's famous line
about how the Constitution is a
parchment
guarantee now at the end of the day
Constitution is words on paper those
words could be manipulated and just
discarded in an instant and that's what
they're trying to do right now it's what
happened in Colorado four activists on a
court court and a Chapman sociology
Professor tried to rewrite the First
Amendment not just for Donald Trump but
for you for me if they're allowed to
succeed then uh they will have
dismantled the foundational legal
principle of this country which is the
freedom of speech they will have ensured
an unprecedented level of political
violence and Discord in the process and
in short they will by their own
definition be guilty of
insurrection and they'll have no reason
to complain when they inevitably pay a
very heavy price for it thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcast